if you can get to a place where you
actually benefit and learn from your
critics it's to your advantage I think
actually the person who closes their ear
too much to the audience's feedback
ultimately is going to lose on
YouTube what was the most hurtful
comment you've ever received and how did
it affect your content or your approach
to YouTube so one of the funniest
comments and we just got a second one
was somebody left a comment and they
said why does
this man have the face of a boy but the
hair of an old
man and someone just on a Instagram Q&A
just
asked H how did your hair become so gray
when you're so
young so you know this is the kind of
encouragement that you get by opening up
the comment section on YouTube what's
funny was I was like I don't know you
know like how do how do I answer that I
was like maybe you think I look younger
because sometimes people go dang you
look kind of young and I'm like well I'm
40 and they're like oh you're 40 and
it's like oh the grade revealed it so
honestly though those don't I I find
those
humorous you know sometimes the most
hurtful comments are the ones that have
some truth in
them um and I learned a quote from Billy
Graham that always stuck with me and
they said that he said if you can get to
a place where you actually benefit and
learn from your critics it's to your
advantage
because the
outrageous negative or weird or toxic
comments that have no basis in reality
those aren't the ones that get under our
skin it's the comments that maybe are
still unfair mean Super rude not
something anyone would ever say to
someone's face but have some level of
Truth in it and I know a lot of
listeners are maybe afraid if someone
calls out their teeth or calls out
something that's true about the the way
they look or that points out some some
something in the way you communicated
and um yeah it's easy for me to take
those things personally I mean I'll take
things personally we just uploaded a
clip from the Seattle Studio where I
just switch while I'm going through
coffee with canel and there was like
massive feedback about like these camera
uh C camera angle switches is horrible
this really breaks my attention one
person was like I can't even trust
somebody who switches their camera this
much something you know so I don't know
so I think that that negative comments
and troll they affect me probably a lot
more than people realize but it's been
one of the skill sets also that I've
that just comes with the territory that
you have to grow so I've intentionally
tried to grow understanding the
principle that you got to have thick
skin but keep a soft
heart um to try to listen to feedback
especially if someone says this felt
inauthentic or I felt like you
misrepresented this or whatever
I think actually the person who closes
their ear too much to the audience's
feedback ultimately is going to lose on
YouTube Hey in just a second we're going
to get right back into this episode of
the think media podcast but if you
haven't heard for a limited time you can
get 90% off the complete package for
growing a successful YouTube channel in
2024 our epic holiday sale includes our
YouTube shorts Master Class AI for
YouTube guide Niche Finder course
YouTube starter kit and a ticket to our
live virtual event the YouTube roadmap
Workshop this bundle of resources is
valued at over
$2,500 but you can get 98% off for a
limited time at think Medias sal.com so
just go to think Medias sal.com before
this offer expires and now let's jump
back into the episode and then of course
you get into the world of like just by
the sheer nature that we sell an online
course or that we could be in the
internet marketing associated with that
World more than Associated it just be
like we obviously Market on the internet
um you know a lot of times people call
you a scam or they'll call you this or
that and I'm I'm incredibly empathetic
to those things and it makes me think
about being thoughtful about just
messaging and communication you know I
have learned though I
heard I can't remember who it was but it
was actually like Warren Buffett it was
Charlie Munger who said if you don't
have 5 to 10% of people complaining that
your prices are too high or that you're
charging too much or
that
um that ultimately you're not charging
enough that you should be pushing your
product your service and so there's a
lot of mindset work to understand to of
course build your product to actually be
excellent in this case we're talking
about a product that's not on course or
write a book I mean same thing like it's
funny that that somebody could complain
about a book that cost $4.99 on Kindle
or 10 bucks on Amazon that took years to
write that's full of gold and wisdom and
somebody could say you know this is a
total ripoff and of course you can
return it you can return the Kindle
return of the Amazon uh audible so it's
kind of being okay with that that like
there's going to be a percentage of
people and as Aristotle said the only
way to avoid
criticism is to say nothing is to do
nothing is to be
nothing and
so I count it a privilege and a a sign
that I'm doing something right when I
get negative comments trolls
Etc um and I try to keep a soft heart
though I don't want to just say it's the
haters and they don't know I want to
keep a vantage point of love for
everybody there empathy for everybody
there and I want to spot Trends I want
to be Discerning enough it's it's if I
get I think this is important math so
because what we there's there's two
equations my friend John aov did haters
math 99 positive comments plus one
negative comment equals one negative
comment the only thing that you think
about is the negative comment I'm
thinking about in the shower man why do
do I really look that old you know like
was that or am I a scam like what's you
know you start like cycling on that
thought well the reverse I guess it's
kind of the same equation but the
reverse equation is Is We I think media
have created the formula of like let's
do the math I get really emotional about
a video is the video succeeding or
performing I'll read one or two negative
comments I'll be like people hate it I
think it's important to take a step back
and and actually think about the like to
dislike ratio which isn't necessarily
shown public they they were hiding
dislikes or whatever but you can see the
percentage in your YouTube studio and in
the YouTube Studio we'll see something
like 96%
which is low for us is how many people
like the video a lot of times it's 97 98
and a half so I didn't do super great in
high school really wasn't for me I think
I had an aptitude for learning but I
wanted to learn practical World skill
skills and Entrepreneurship and not
necessarily the traditional education
system so I want to say I maybe averaged
3.0 29 or 32 GPA and I remember on test
you know if I got a 80 Six B you know if
I got a B+ even an A minus you know that
was amazing
97% is such an insane approval rating
with most of those people hitting the
like button actually are enjoying the
content getting value and they're being
silent a lot of times the most vocal
people on the internet are the most hurt
toxic
cynical
critical and you got to ask the question
how is it that they even have time to
type and give that response busy
productive ambitious enterprising
individuals are building they're
watching learning and taking action and
they're not necessarily going to get
involved in that level that's not to say
that someone shouldn't leave a negative
comment and that's true about all people
but it is to say that I've got to look
at the math and I still get caught up in
my emotions because I'll get one
negative comment on the podcast and I'll
spin off even a title crew in slack or
something with you know Kyle and Steph
and I'll be like something's wrong with
this video I think we missed it are we
like did we say it wrong should we use
this different word in the title and
it's also nice I realize shows how
irrational I am I'll get like Nolan just
being like I think the the the title's
fine why is why are people offended and
here's my thing I read one
comment 500 likes positive 10 likes
negative 25 positive comments one
comment pointing something out if I was
more objective as I'm trying to be here
as we evaluate the emotions I get caught
up in it's not really a big deal like
that's all tracking mathematically as it
should be yet I think we sometimes can
overemphasize the negative comment so I
think there's something about doing the
math and the long road around the
mountain to pull the principal out is if
the video had a 60% like to dislike
Ratio or there's a crazy theme of A lot
of people and sometimes I've seen this a
couple episodes they've been like I love
your stuff I normally love what you're
doing I I would love think media podcast
love the team this episode fell off I
think we need to be open to that and I
think we're in a really dangerous
place if those types of feedback we
close our heart to now ego is getting a
little too big Pride's getting a little
too big that's a little bit more rare
and so I think it's look at the big data
the data is there to give you feedback
and we should be listening to that it's
going to make us better content creator
question for you are you finally ready
to commit to starting and growing your
YouTube Chan channel in 2024 if the
answer is yes you're not going to want
to miss our epic holiday sale going on
right now where you can get over 98% off
of a bundle of our online courses and
downloadable action guides that will
help you crush it on YouTube just click
the link around this video to get access